dessiner un voyage une écume de nuit ou
modeler lampard fait un dialogue entre
images du réel et visions fantastiques
de la sculpture à la peinture en passant
par l'aquarelle teresa gina nes qui ne
se donne aucune limite
j'avais envie un peu d'expérience
d'expérimenter tous et chaque
chaque technique ma porte autre chose je
suis très sensible aux vibrations de
tout ce qui m'entoure enfer et la nature
en particulier
voilà des animaux et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que quand je suis
quelque part c'est pas tant le paysage
que je vois c'est surtout toutes les
émotions tout ce que ça tout ce que jean
magazine en voyant ça c'est ça qui me
reste est en fait c'est cette empreinte
la réunis dans l'exposition variations
ces 42 oeuvres sont une palette de
ressenti un travail récompensé par les
prix du jury 2013 et 2015 des automnales
et du salon influence de guyancourt lors
de ses différents concours j'ai pu
découvrir plusieurs facettes de son
travail et à travers son travail j'ai
découvrir j'ai découvert aussi une
personne et à travers cette personne on
a voulu voilà construire quelque chose
ensemble présenter ses oeuvres présenter
son travail le travail de toute une vie
on a des oeuvres qui sont depuis les
années 1970 des couleurs aux ombres une
oeuvre qui a su évoluer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
comme une rétrospective des émotions de
l'artiste
[Musique]